now the big news of the day was fauci
and friends returning to capitol hill
joining me now to break it all down dr
ramin oscawy
cardiologist and ceo of foxhall
cardiology and dr
steven smith founder of the smith center
for infectious diseases
and urban health all right guys i want
to start off with dr fauci
taking aim at a new study showing
positive results
for hydroxychloroquine the henry ford
hospital
study that was published was a
non-controlled retrospective cohort
study
that was confounded by a number of
issues including the fact that many of
the people who are receiving
hydroxychloroquine were also receiving
corticosteroids
so that study is a flawed study and i
think anyone who examines it carefully
is that it is not a randomized
placebo-controlled trial
i don't have any horse in the game one
way or the other
i just look at the data dr smith he just
looks at the data
was the study flawed and what about what
fauci said
well i mean we know it's not randomized
controlled study
and it was randomized control but they
did control for steroid exposure and
still
hydroxychloroquine confer to benefit the
bigger problem is that
uh dr fauci has taken aim at this study
for not being
randomized controlled study where he's
endorsed other studies
that also were similar observational
studies including the infamous landsat
study which of course was fraud
and that when he cites all these other
studies he doesn't always name them but
they have to be
uncontrolled studies there aren't that
many randomized controls
so it's disturbing they're also there
are controlled studies even the first
fire logic
study done by the french was it had
control it wasn't randomized
they were good controls and that the
controls were actually less thick than
the
drug receiving patients the drug
receiving patients cleared virus quicker
similarly has been controlled placebo
studies in india
again not randomized but the similar
controls not the health care workers
that were the controls didn't decide not
to take hydroxyl or
these these studies are controlled and
on top of it
i remember correctly shelley wolff my
dad's friend and actress
mentor and dr fauci who was my mentor i
appreciate what he did for me they
published their their big findings and
wagner's granulomatosis back in the
early 70s at an uncontrolled study
looking at the effects of cytokine
pregnancy and which worked i credit them
with that that was
uncontrolled so it's got to look
at it the same way yeah so it turns out
it turns out let me jump in here it
turns out dr oscary that
dr fauci doesn't
believe that these randomized controlled
studies are always necessary
but for some reason they're necessary in
the middle of a pandemic where we have
hundreds of thousands of people dying
in a situation where people want answers
and realistic hope
no one's saying it's panacea or any of
that
but what did you make of that testimony
today just specifically on that and any
other thoughts
well unfortunately i think what uh what
steve has eloquently pointed out is
lying by omission is still lying
it's very important to understand that
that study did correct for steroid use
but it also pointed out what we seem to
see in
covid which is a steroid paradox where
if you have very mild disease steroids
probably don't help you
whereas if you have more severe disease
as quantified perhaps by a crp
of greater than 20 steroid dexamethasone
specifically
may be immensely helpful and what i what
i'm hearing is someone
who is frankly very manipulative
and dishonest as a scientist so
the cdc completed an investigation
on covet transmission or they
observed it at a sleep away camp with
children and counselors
and there's some severe limitations in
the study but here's what the cdc
concluded this investigation adds to the
body of evidence
demonstrating that children of all ages
are susceptible to sars kova
ii infection and contrary to early
reports
might play an important role in
transmission dr
osqui what does that tell you should we
run from schools and keep our kids
locked in the house
no i think it means we should believe
our lying eyes
we should see that kids simply don't get
that sick
we're not seeing wards icu's and
pediatric
hospitals full of sick kids on
ventilators when children
do get coveted or probably more reliably
test positive for rna fragments of covet
they simply don't get that sick
this buttresses the idea kids need
in-person schools and they need to go
five days a week
and we need to get the show on the road
just like they're doing in sweden
and a number of other european countries
here's an interesting point dr smith uh
nancy pelosi uh is often saying that
look we just need to listen to the
scientists
it not not not scientists were actually
treating patients
but the scientists but behind the scenes
we found out something different she
reportedly said to treasury secretary
steve mnuchin
and white house chief of staff mark
meadows that dr deborah burks
is the worst wow what horrible hands
you're in pelosi said
so i guess if you don't preen for the
cameras and posed for people magazine
pelosi uh trashes you what about that
yeah the whole thing is unbelievable
that again
dr fauci is right that we have to look
at data that's correct we have to look
at data fairly
and that has not been done and to
demonize people
based on their interpretation of the
data that's just unbelievably wrong
i just can't get over this country's
response to a drug that is so safe and
does work
um it's scandalous gentlemen
you've been two voices of reason and a
very tumultuous and difficult time both
for science
for the people suffering for the country
as a whole and we really appreciate you
thanks so much